we're going to be dancing we're going to
be singing we're going to be keeping
people's names out of our mouths and
we're going to be giving out awards i'm
doing the same so let's jump from the
grammys to chris rock's former home at
snl the oscar slap continues to be a hot
topic of conversation and non-stop comic
material
oh wow i'm gonna present this award and
i trust that you people will stay 500
feet away from me i just think chris
rock handled himself with such a plum
and it's like such a pro he's my king so
just seeing him stand the way he did and
hold his composure man i love him so
much i need to caution everybody remain
in your seats and keep your hands to
yourself
they said uh comedians have to wear
these now at a ward show the jabs kept
coming with snl making the slap a
running joke throughout the show i
always knew hitchhiking
keep my wife's name
[Applause]
during his acceptance speech will smith
said love will make you do crazy things
you know what else makes you do crazy
things crazy
the academy will meet on april 18th to
decide will's fate as for his future
projects calm down i'm come e.t has
learned bad boys 4 and will's netflix
movie fast and loose are both currently
in early development and far from being
made will's apple tv plus movie
emancipation is in the can but a release
date has not yet been set
a source tells e.t will is aware of the
backlash and his friends believe there
is a lot of anger in will and that he
needs to take a break from acting go to
therapy and sort out his issues longtime
friend denzel washington broke his
silence on the subject at bishop td
jake's international leadership summit
on saturday i want to say what we talked
about but
there but for the grace of god go any of
us i don't know all the ins and outs of
the situation i know the only solution
was prayer
[Music]
you